hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
writing the nih shared instrumentation
grant strategies for success
i am jennifer woods of labyrinth and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labrus
and organized by thermal fisher
scientific
the world leader in servicing science
thermal pressure scientific provides
complete workflows
from cryo-electron microscopic
structural determination
of macromolecular complexes in native
state
to 3d reconstruction of tissues and
cells
thermo fisher scientific solutions help
unlock mysteries of
underlying protein function and cellular
process
bridging the gap between basic science
and translational therapeutics
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions
you may have during the presentation to
do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please follow the process to obtain your
credit by clicking on the continuing
education credits window
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
christopher
dan consultant at medcom consulting
dr christopher dan has over 40 years
experience first as a medical researcher
and as a medical writer and writing
consultant in biopharmaceutical
government and academic settings he
received his
ma and phd in genetics and molecular
biology
from indiana university and university
of michigan
and was a postdoctoral scholar at
university of vermont
he was formerly a senior writer in
academic and pharmaceutical settings
a peer-reviewed medical journal editor
and is currently
a consultant in producing grants at
stanford
medical school in 2005 to 2010
he established the clinical publication
sufficient at genentech in california
he had served on the faculty at
dartmouth medical school
and norris cotton cancer center and
consults with stanford medical school
and the university of california at san
francisco
dr dan worked through the nih ninds
as a peer review peer review grant
consultant
he lectured widely in academic and
biopharma settings
on nih career and research grants
manuscript writing and basic scientific
writing for scientists
but after that you may now begin your
presentation
all right thank you very much and
welcome everyone
uh today i want to talk to you about a
very specific kind of grant at the
national institutes of health
or the nih uh less every year called
an s10 grant it's a it's a shared
instrumentation grant
and i'm going to talk to you about the
specifics of the grant
and particularly how
to win the grant how to get get it
funded uh they're very very competitive
but uh certainly winnable and uh there
are a number of things you have to pay
attention to
and these are grants that i've dealt
with along with the more common
uh r grants like r1 and program project
grants the po ones at
a number of institutions currently at
stanford medical school
and dartmouth school of medicine
so essentially the s10 grand and that is
uh the s
means shared and it's it's uh uh it's an
acronym given to these types of grants
so i'll use it sort of
uh loosely to refer to all of them
but it's a it's it's a grant that funds
the purchase
or update of an expensive shared used
piece of instrumentation
usually uh well over a half a million to
a million dollars
that is not supported by other nih
funding mechanisms such as the r01
or research grant or the program project
grant po1
because they don't fund the large pieces
of instrumentation
this grant does but before i talk to you
about the
nih grant which is what i'm going to
focus on
in full disclosure i want to let you
know that the national science
foundation nsf also
has a program called the major
instrumentation program
or mri program that lets
uh instruments of a hundred thousand to
one
just under one million and then 1
million to 4 million those are two
tracks
the uh uh that are
for purchase of instrumentation and the
emphasis there is on scientific and
engineering instrumentation
and for research and training
specifically
training uh the next generation of
uh on instruments uh so
it's it's uh more in the direction
of uh not only research but training
but unlike the nih the nsf grant is a
cost-sharing grant it requires a 30
cost share total project cost so your
institution would have to put up 30
of the funds for that unlike the nih
grant
so let's switch to the nih grant um
you know and and i don't know
everybody's background
on the nih but uh i'll make it very
simple the nih is a very large institute
that has
over 27 specific institutes that many of
you have heard about
such as the national cancer institute
national
institute of mental health heart and
lung
blood institute and so forth and then a
number of offices
there are two uh there's an institute in
an office that
that is um behind
the shared instrumentation grid i'm
going to talk about those the first is
the office of research infrastructure
program so
orip this is an office at nih
that's dedicated to supporting research
infrastructure
so things like large uh
instruments and uh you know
pieces that go with it such as computers
um and i'll talk a little bit about more
about the
orip but that's one of the institutes
that funds
or is uh sponsors the nih uh
instrumentation grant
the other is the national institute of
general medical sciences
uh which is uh you know lesser-known
institute to some extent
it supports uh and it's very wise
ranging and it's in its uh support uh
basic research
uh such as the foundations for disease
diagnosis
treatment and prevention uh it has
quite a few offices within the
the institute but that's one of the
sponsors for the instrumentation grant
and it's interested in co-funding s10
applications that include research
project within its mission
and uh the mission you'll have to go to
nigms website and look at it but it
supports research
in clinical areas that affect multiple
organ systems that's pretty wide-ranging
but that's what their
their main interest is so if any of your
specific research uh that you're doing
uh it say if the nih is in this area
that
that would add uh some advantage to you
for an instrumentation grant also nigms
is particularly interested in uh
promoting
um participation in the uh
institutional development award or idea
states there are
certain states in the united states that
um
are underfunded for nih and that is uh
that's why the nih is looking at
co-funding applications from those
states encouraging sharing and
collaboration among
institutes and programs in states
and here are the states that um are
historically have had low levels of nih
funding and
and if you're in one of these states and
applying for an s10 grant that will give
you an advantage
or if you're participating say with
another
uh institute um uh or
university or whatever it is from that
state that will give you the
some advantage okay so
there are every year uh let from the nih
three specific uh separate
instrumentation grants or the s10 grants
there's the the big program basic
instrumentation grant which is limited
to institutions
that have not received instrumentation
funding of 250 000 in one dollar
or greater in any of the federally
fiscal years from
2018 to 2021. so if you haven't gotten
any informat
any funding uh of that amount of greater
then you're eligible for that grant and
they are limited to instruments that are
only 25 000 to 250 000
these are things like basic sorters
confocal microscopes ultramicrometers
gels gelameters computer systems that
sort of thing
and the number at the bottom par number
is the announcement number these are the
program
announcements and uh if you were to type
that into
uh your google uh you know search you
will find
the announcement and uh we'll talk about
that in a minute
then there's the shared instrumentation
grant this is one of the most popular
sig program that provides the uh between
50 000 and 100 and 600 000
and generally when combined with
institutional support it
enables a purchase of very powerful
expensive equipment
and that has again a separate number for
uh its announcement
and then the final high-end hei program
which is between 600 000
and two million so for example the agi
would support the purchase of
of a cryo-electron microscope from
thermal fissure for example
or anything that would cost up to two
million dollars
the the instrument as i will mention in
a minute may be more than 2000 but it
will only let 2000
for that particular grant and um
we're going to talk about the grant but
want to
know that every single one of these each
of these
has the same requirements uh
so they don't vary it's the only big
variable here is the
instrument costs so
the main thing i want to emphasize and
again i am going to repeat myself
because some of this information is
really vital and a lot of people miss
first of all
the nih instrumentation grant program
supports purchase of state-of-the-art
instrument to enhance research of
federally funded investigators
investigators that have nih funded our
funding already
and i'll i'll discuss the specifics of
that so
you have to be you have to have
investigators that are funded by the nih
to start
the other thing is that usually these
instruments are too expensive to
purchase through a regular
project grant so these instruments that
are obtained from these s10 grants are
shared
which makes the programs cost effective
uh cost efficient
and beneficial to thousands of pis uh
in institutions um so
this is not a grant that you yourself
can apply for uh on your own for your
lab this is
shared and it's shared amongst number of
investigators
and these grants are awarded to
institutions throughout the united
states
um to meet the needs of
nih-funded investigators and other
biomedical research
and here is a map that's shown that
equal portion of instruments in nih
funded research projects in each of the
nation's four
geographical regions and it's
approximately equal
throughout a little bit more in the
northeast but for the most part uh equal
in
specifically uh s10 grants
and um
that is really the number of grants
uh this is reflecting the number of
grants that have been won or the success
rate
um and then this is a showing a graph
of the types of technologies or types of
instruments that are left
by um by by uh these grants
and uh the rewards and requests and so
you see
a lot about the optical instruments mass
spectrometers biomedical imagers things
like that that are quite
quite popular that are let but
a whole range of other instruments such
as
nmr dpr and cell sorters and electron
microscopes and so forth
it doesn't mean that the nih does not
support an electron microscope
or a molecular interaction system as
much as an optical instruments
it just means that there are fewer
applications
uh and therefore fewer of those grants
left
there's no uh you know particular
interest in the
uh in the nih should say well we really
want
to find more optical instruments than
electron microscopes that's not the case
and this is a graph of the uh
amount of money over the last several
years for
these s10 grants that are let so
in 2021 the orip
uh commits it must commit 30 million
dollars for s10 programs but this is
decreased
by 45 from 2012 so
this reduction over the number of years
is
makes these grants increasingly
competitive
however the good news is that the
general success rate for these grants is
about
18 to 20 percent that's the number of uh
grants that are left versus uh submitted
number of grants uh that are that are
awarded and uh
that success rate is generally higher
than
say research project grants r01 grants
or program project grants or
even career awards which are a little
bit higher for example
the national cancer institute in 2019
had a success rate for their research
project grants of only eight percent so
these are very fairly high success rates
which is the good news so the grant
parameters are very strict here
and you'll have to make your proposal
convincing if you want to get your
uh your application noticed
those the reviewers on these grants
scrutinize the detail
it's a lot of detail and you miss it in
one essential detail
they basically will pass it over but
first you've got to pass the eligibility
requirements to get one of these grants
and craft a proposal that they'll
impress reviewers
so there are certain strategies that
i'll talk about that get your
application through the process
so first of all these grants are not for
clinical trials that does that means
they are not directly funding research
uh
activities that are clinical trials and
therefore not subjected
to the nih reporting requirements for
clinical trials which is
extensive um the request for an
instrument
must be justified by the needs of active
nih-funded research projects
it is permitted for a funded instrument
to be used for the conduct of
of human subject research but not used
for a specific
trial clinical trial or
are solely for diagnostic purposes so
you can't
ask for an mri or a pet instrument
to do simply diagnostics of patient
diagnostics
this is for research research projects
and again these are shared okay
first of all the awards are issued for
only one year matching funds aren't
required unlike nsf
they must show a shared need among at
least
three major users and we'll talk about
what a major and a minor user are
to carry out their nih-funded research
the nih expects institutions that
compete for instrumentation awards to
show
support for these imp for for these
instruments for its infrastructure so
you have to have space to house the
instrument technical personnel to
maintain it
post awards service contracts to uh
maintain and operate the instrument and
find us to maintain the facility
none of those things can be funded by
this grant
the grant is only for the instrument
so the the
pi uh principal investigator project
director
program director must be not
knowledgeable facility manager they must
be knowledgeable
on electron microscopy for example
it's important to have the expertise to
so that the instrument will survive
they do not need to have active nih
research grant
or other research support but it's
better if they are funded it's better
for the application so there must be as
i mentioned
at least three major users who can
demonstrate a substantial need for the
instrument
and they must be r01 funded they must
have a major
research project grant of the nih to
advance the work proposed
ideally it would be good to have at
least
five to eight major users and i'll talk
a little bit about how they're mixed
the minor users don't need to have major
funding like an r1 they can have other
funding
like a career award a k award or a
non-nh award like
department of defense or department of
energy or even a private foundation
but everyone that applies or on the
grant must be affiliated with the
applicant organization
and must be registered on era commons
and if you don't know what er
accountants is
look it up on the nh website it's
basically the application it's the place
where you register
who you are with the nih and every every
investigator has a separate era commons
um
[Music]
place on on their website major users
um pis must be on a major basic research
grant such as um
what they call a dp1 or dp2 which is a
pioneer or new and
innovative award those are very large
awards they're very rare to get but
they are major rewards program projects
p01s and our
research projects r1 there's other our
grants like the r35 or the r37
that that um you can look up those those
are also considered to be
major or basic research grants or a
cooperative agreement with the nih which
are called u grants like u01 or u54
those are those are if you have one of
those
you can be an active you can be a major
user
a pi with a training grant a t32
or a ko1 or koa or ff
grant fellowship or with a small
business innovative research sbir
or technology transfer sttr cannot be a
major user so
uh you have to have one of the awards at
the top there
um awards from multi-pis are counted
only once
so if you have three pis that are doing
say work in a similar area
but that they're basically all part of
the same group doing the same research
that's only counted one towards this
requirement you have to have a separate
uh grant and a separate project to be a
second
major user at least three major users
must
meet this requirement so if you have
additional major users
say four or five more they can be added
with other funding such as the national
science foundation department of energy
department of defense or private
foundation
and again five to eight major users are
ideal but probably not
more than that that's it's a balancing
act i'm going to talk to you about this
is
some people think oh i'm going to put in
15 major users that'll really impress
them that's not
a good idea all major users must
demonstrate
a significant need for the instrument in
the research so that's the real
requirement right there
and that'll be uh in the application
i'll talk to you about that'll be clear
so there can be individual research a
group of investigators within the same
department
investigative groups from several
departments at the applicant institute
or
nih extramural awardees from other
nearby institutions but
investigators on nih training grants and
contracts are not eligible to be major
users again
so um the main thing when you want to
start one of these grants is you want to
identify
at least three individuals who
are could be considered major use and
have a substantial need for the
equipment
again it's more better to have something
like five or eight
they must be a pd or pi on an active
research award
grant or cooperative agreement in basic
or translational research
this is um a little repetitive but i
this is the actual
wording the nih let's so i want to make
sure that you are very clear
on what these groups are what what a
major user is
um again the award given to multi pis
is counted only once nih training or
fellowship grants tnfs
uh do not count okay and as other other
research uh grant stuff
other major user investigators can be
added
again from nsf doe dod private
foundations etc
provided they are engaged in basic or
translational research and can
demonstrate a substantial need so every
major user
will have in the application um
what research they're doing what the
actual number of the research project is
what it is and how
the instrument is going to help them
move that research forward
um the researcher can be from the same
department or different departments
divisions
or schools excuse me at the same at the
african institution or
from nearby a regional institutions
the major users uh that come from
distant
institutions must demonstrate the need
for the instrument and describe the
plans for how
they will regularly access the
instrument housed in
another institution institution shared
facility so if you were
from the university of connecticut and
you have
uh in the major users from mit and they
get the instrument and how's it there
how are you going to get up there to run
your samples
or how the sample is going to get there
and how is that
all going to work so um that that's a
little more tricky
if you're in another institution but
it's certainly something that
um as 10 grandsons have seen
minor users um may have funding but
they're but not
nih research grants necessarily or they
may have new
new investigators who don't have funding
but including such early investigators
is really
important uh to your s10 proposal
because you're highlighting
these supplemental users to show the
impact
uh of users more than just your major
you know your user base of major
researches and it has a larger dynamic
impact so if you can show
a wide uh impact from this instrument
you're going in
in a number of areas and there's a great
need
um what you want to be really careful of
is that you don't overwhelm the
instruments so that you don't have so
many users
that the the reviewer will look at it as
um as the amount a lot of time
and there's i'll show you that in a
minute and say you know there's just way
too much
um use for this and it's just not going
the major users have the priorities so
they must i'll show you the percentage
requirement on that
institution requirements domestic public
or private institutions of higher
education non-profits
such as hospitals health professional
schools
and research organizations are can apply
applicant institutions must demonstrate
a commitment towards
continuing support for the use and
maintenance of the
instrument that's important
and this is uh my my uh graphic for
how this all works so on the left hand
side
you see the instant the research
institute at the top they're letting
uh writing an hei or a high-end
instrument grant to the nih
the nih then reviews it over a period of
months
if it's successful the money then goes
directly to the institute
and that's committed to support the use
and maintenance of the instrument and
that in that is your institution will
have an advisory committee that will be
named in the application
that will oversee uh this instrument's
use
and the one person that will be focused
on will be the program director the
principal investigator who will also be
part of the facility uh where the
instrument is
maintained so they have a requirement
and i'll tell you what that is for that
instrument in that facility
but the major and minor users
are all the ones that use this
instrument okay
in the research um the instrument can be
used
also um by other institutions
if they want to pay for its time
as long as there is uh there is a lot of
time for it
but again the major users
and then the minor users take priority
on the instrument
okay and here you know we might see uh
five major users and maybe four minor
users or something of that
nature that um show the
substantial need for the instrument
so the high-end grant
and again all three of the grants that i
mentioned are all the same in terms of
the application requirements
the funding opportunity par 2126
um it's to make available
high and i'm putting this up here
because this is what the united says
high-end cutting-edge instruments that
can only be justified
on a shared use basis that are needed
for nice
projects in basic translational clinical
biomedical and biobehavioral research
uh be careful of that word clinical it
doesn't mean that you can do a clinical
trial just means that
you can do research and run
samples for human subjects as well as
say
other other other other samples animal
animal samples the hei program is a
single item
allows the single items of purchase or
upgrade expensive leading edge
specialized commercially available
instrument
or integrated instruments annotation
system
and that is one in which the components
when used in conjunction with one
another perform a function that no
single component can provide that's very
important
because the components must be dedicated
to the system and not used independently
that's very very important to uh to
emphasize
and this is what on the right the actual
front page of the uh
rfa or the uh par
looks like they all have the same
structures
uh the the three major grants and they
all have
the same eight month review criteria so
applications are generally due june 1st
uh earliest date you can kind of may
first
the review uh merit review of september
uh and then the advisory council review
which is the second
series of reviews in january and the
award is made in february so it's an
eight month cycle
um the purpose of the hei program
is uh again to encourage applications
from groups
of investigators to purchase a high-end
specialized and commercially available
and the award is
thousand six hundred thousand in one
dollar the
sig program is cut off at six hundred
thousand
there's no maximum price for the
instrument but the maximum award is two
million
and there are things like biomedical
imagers high throughput robotic screen
systems x-ray defrost fractometers
mass specs nuclear magnetic nmr nuclear
magnetic resonance imaging spectrometers
dna and protein synthesis
sequencers uh you know biosensors
electron and light microscopes and cell
sources
this is not an exhaustive list and if
you have a question whether the
instrument you want
is um going to be acceptable um
i can give you more information on that
so the kinds of things they don't allow
are things like developing new
instruments
uh the agi will not um
fund anything less than six hundred
thousand and one of course the sig will
multiple instruments bundled together
institutional administrative systems
clinical management systems
instruments used for purely clinical
care like billable care now
software unless it's an integrated in
the operation of the instrument or
necessary for its
output standalone workstations are not
allowed
general purpose equipment things like
machine shop equipment instruments to
furnish a
facility autoclaves hoods
uh animal care facilities equipment for
routine
maintaining maintaining infrastructure
standard computer networks or data
storage systems are not allowed to be
purchased as
are disposable devices office furniture
supplies or
any renovation or alteration to the
space
for your uh to house your equipment
the shared facility that is not allowed
on this
what is allowed is high-end stand-alone
instruments and
um the applications for stand-alone
computer system like super computers or
computer cluster and data storage
systems
will be considered if it's solely
dedicated to the instrument
uh the biomedical research the
instrument that you're using for that
so to promote cost-effectiveness
the nih encourages optimal sharing and
fosters
a multi-disciplinary environment uh the
instrument should be
put in a core facility whenever possible
foreign-made instruments are allowed uh
they didn't used to be but they are now
with the nih so the first steps in
putting this uh application together is
um uh to promote you know a
cost effectiveness optimal sharing and
collaborative uh
environment you want to get it into an
integrated core facility
uh and each applicant institution must
propose a pi or pd who can assume
administrative as well of scientific
oversight so they'll be responsible for
requesting
cost extension no cost extensions
preparing a final performance
report in collaboration with the
institutional officials at the end of
the project period
prepare annual use of the instrument for
fear
four years and help maintain the
equipment and train personnel
so that that is all going to be costs
that the institute will have to bear
but the pd is going to be responsible
for all those things
an advisory committee is going to be
named uh from your institution
and they oversee the usage of the
equipment things like
maximum use time allocation delayed plan
for the day-to-day management and safe
operation
plan to ensure that access to the
instruments
is limited to the users whose projects
have received approval
from your institutional human subjects
animal welfare and biosafety committees
that's important a financial plan for
the long-term operation and maintenance
of the instrument during the post-award
period
relocation if necessary uh
within or outside the institution or
change of ownership uh and recommending
a new pd or pi
if if the need arises so that's the
advisory committee's job
and um we'll talk a little bit about
what goes into that
um you can submit more than one
application
uh provided that each is distinct
scientifically
they won't accept the nih won't accept
the duplicates
uh or highly overlapping uh in
applications such as you put in a new
application that's submitted before
issuance of the summary statement uh
from the
review of another a0 overlapping a0
which is the a new application
or a resubmission at a1 or resubmission
that is submitted before the issuance of
the summary statement of the new
application
or an application that has been a
substantial overlap with another
application pending approval
okay so there's there can't be any
overlap and there can't be uh overlap
on this resubmission or new new uh
application so they all have to be
distinct
so the hdi application essentially that
the guts of it uh really
um are the instrumentation plan and
letters of support i'll
tell you about some other pieces that
need to go into it but
i'm going to discuss these items here
the uh a resubmission introduction which
uh is only for an a1 the justification
need expertise to technical expertise
research projects section
okay of major minor users
um summary tables administrative
uh section uh institutional commitment
and overall benefit those are the those
are the required sections
of this particular grant and then
there's letters of support and i'll talk
to you a little bit about
what goes into there other things that
go into the grant are very much like a
regular grant like a research grant a
project summary an abstract
a narrative um why is the instrument
important
for research a bibliography obviously
will be from your research project
section and then there'll be a section
on the equipment what is it
it's manufactured model it's you know
features accessories
a budget breakdown of the main
instrument and accessories and
quote from the vendor uh appropriate
discounts etc
is required but let's talk about
preparing the actual guts of the
application
which goes into them and i'm not trying
to present this
with you writing tons of notes and
saying i've got to write all the stance
all in the
rfi rfa it's all in the par
that you look up that gives you all the
details you need to write it
it it's quite extensive it's not simple
um but you need to read the program
announcement
before you do anything okay because
um in very detail and also they change
uh year to year
somewhat um but you will get rejected
without a question if you don't uh if
you don't include
a clear um you know
a clear answer to each of each of the
sections you have to have
um i mean you you really your job is to
communicate the need for the user group
for the particular instrument to study
to the study panel by highlighting the
major criteria
utilizing scoring a grant these grants
and that is
justifying its need do you have
technical expertise
the research projects need it the
administration oversight is good
institutional commitment is there and
the overall benefit is clear
any of these are poorly addressed the
application will fail without question
they will fail so let's talk about some
of these sections what goes into them
first of all it's justification
that's very important nine pages scope
of the proposal with the user group
instrument costs and instrument
capabilities
history of the core facility where
you're going to house it
describe the instrument and historical
perspective about the development
evolution
you must show you understand its
technology appreciate the pros and cons
of the application and perhaps even
the instrument is it has gone through a
number of iterations in each
each each iteration has new capabilities
and why that's important that you
understand it
rationale for selecting this particular
instrument important to the research
objectives
uh compare the requested instrument with
other
similar commercially available so if
you're applying for a specific
electron microscope and there's others
similar to it you want to
show this is the one you need because of
its
um you know capabilities that you know
the others don't have pertaps
access to existing equipment and why
either is unavailable or unsuitable
summary of the proc proximal inventory
of similar items that might have been
used but can't be used for one reason or
another
and then you need letters from the
owners of the or the core directors of
other instruments that attest to the
reason these instruments are just not
available
so this brings up a question about how
are you going to
get you know data uh in your
you have to show preliminary data on
that instrument
in order for it to really be convincing
so these are going to be
rented instruments perhaps or
instruments that other institutions in
which you've sent samples to
and they just aren't available or it's
not a suitable instrument
well there's no other one like it out
there that really can give you the
answers that you need
okay the technical expertise has to be
there you want to describe the
day-to-day
use its oversight maintenance of the
instrument
uh expertise of the pi the user group
and the staff you want to have to show
that you have the technical expertise
particularly the pi the pd the technical
scientific advisory committee that has
to be in there you want to list advisors
and consultants who will
give you advice on things like
experimental design
use and application of the instrument
data management and infrastructure that
will support the use of it
um detail a review of the biosafety
biohazard protocols
and the core facility has to be well
defined and
available to the faculty beyond just the
users group so i'll show you that in a
minute
that's that's here um here is current
wild cornell
medicine um and and that's the core
microscopy
and image analysis core facility that's
on the web and it's available to anybody
um through the web so here you see a
specific
a a a web page and if you were to click
on the microscopy section in the upper
left hand corner would give you the
the the page on the right showing the
microscopy offering so that it shows a
confocal
multi-photon electron uh microscopy
automated
optical microscopy and white field so
each of these uh each of these
instruments or groups of instruments or
maybe i don't know there may be more
than one electron microscope for example
all have a description of what they are
what's available and an ability to
reserve the equipment
um as well as to submit publication and
grant information and so forth
uh that would have been used on that but
the main thing is that it's for
for core users only so these are the
major in the
and the the minor users um
are able to reserve the instrument in
some places you can
submit a uh request to use the
instrument
if you're outside of that group but the
main thing i'm pointing out here is that
it would be good
to uh form a webpage like this even
though you don't have the instrument yet
showing what it will look like you can
do a mock-up and show
what it would look like for the mih
reviewers saying yeah they're really
serious this is where it's going this is
uh
all they're saying about it how to
reserve it all of that's there
you've really put that together that's
very important here's another example
at the massachusetts institute of
technology
a core facility for the telos archicad
g2 cryo tem or transmission electron
microscope
and that sits there and it shows you
it's what it is what its
capabilities and specifications are what
kind of applications it's used in
uh it gives you some resources where
it's located
how to reserve it and who to contact and
all that has to be in there
okay so it's important that um
that kind of thing is in in your in your
grant it would even be good to show a
picture of it
uh just a mock-up of the page so the
research projects is really where the
rubber meets the road in this grant
okay this is a summary uh you know of
the composition of the major user groups
who the other schools divisions
departments where they are
and it should convey the broad use and
broad use of the instrument and support
of it has within the research community
they would have the minor users um okay
with project descriptions this section
will have these things in it that their
name the specific
aims very much like a research grant a
background of significance
preliminary results that validate the
need for the use of the application of
the instrument
the data will be should be ideally
gathered on the requested instrument if
you have one that you can get at another
institute
by by reserving it or if you've leased
it or somehow
able to use another instrument like it
or the same one
uh what are your experimental procedures
and protocols okay
demonstrate your understanding of the
use of the instrument and its
difficulties that may be encountered
the use application and need uh for the
instrument in fulfilling the aims
okay that you've listed on your on your
project
okay you want to address specific
accessories if
if there aren't any so here's the
important thing
you do not want to cut
and paste your specific aims from your
research project so let's say you're a
major user
you have an r01 grant that's nih funded
and um you aren't you aren't putting
that down here
what you're doing is you're justifying
you're not justifying the science of the
previously funded grants that's already
been done the nih has already
passed judgment on that and given you
the money you're
showing the need for the instrument to
complete the research
so your aims and your results and your
procedures and protocols are all about
the experiments that you're going to run
on this instrument and how that
is going to provide you with the answers
that you need that have not
that have eluded you to this point okay
so it's very important that you're not
cutting and pasting
your aims and so forth in your
background
from already funded research so the
research
sections should describe the benefit of
the instrument
to enhance your projects the research
projects the major users and then the
minor
users so you want to avoid any
redundancy
if the projects are if they have similar
protocols
and you want to make them distinct okay
you want to make sure that um
that they're distinct in your
presentation
and uh they must demonstrate again
substantial research need it's got to be
convincing
that you need this in order to complete
your research
or let's say your research took off in a
new direction in the third year of its
funding
and you now see the need for this
instrument that is going to give you
go into these areas that you really need
to explore
so you want to highlight the equipment
needed show how it'll expand and broaden
your research that's the main thing
so you already need to you you need to
show how the instrument will transform
uh what the nih has already funded
you want to want to show that the
instrument extends to science not just
fulfills the needs of the grant
and again preliminary data is important
on
similar or the same instrument present
data include graphs and tables that's
very important to the
reviewers of this grant then there's two
summary tables
that lists your users the role in the
projects their title of the project the
funding source including the grant
number and project
percent use you also list the user's
uh use of the of the instrument
applications and accessories and
features needed
and again three of the major users must
need the requested
options or accessories to justify their
inclusion
that has to be shown very clearly the
administrative section
uh is not a throwaway a lot of people
think it might be but it is really
important
to convince the study panel that the
instrument will be well used
and cared for that's very important
you're gonna they're gonna give you two
million dollars for an instrument
they're gonna know it's going you in uh
into a court facility and cared for so
if
you describe the facility
describe this location in space uh
including architectural engineering
drawings if needed
renovations discuss and administration
an advisory committee that oversees its
access its scheduling
disputes uh resolution
uh the role and composition of your
technical advisory committee
uh detailed financial plan including
plans for income from charging the its
use
if you have charging other people
outside instrument maintenance ongoing
support of the service contract has to
have a service contract
uh support for the corps uh and
technical staff
uh that oversee uh the um the instrument
in its facility and an operating budget
showing the first four years that
includes anticipate expenditures for
staff supplies
instrument uh you know usage hours
anticipated
recharge income things like that again
the
grant will only pay for the incident
none none of these things are paid for
but they need to know that they're taken
care of
institutional commitment is extremely
important
okay that your institute will support
the core of the staff and the instrument
to keep it
for instrumented upkeep and the training
uh in it and a letter from your dean or
chair
that commits support in perpetuity of
the service contract for the requested
instrument so
the dean has to say we will provide uh x
dollars per year
for the service contract from company
abc
uh to to maintain this instrument and it
should be a commitment to cover
any cost of renovations okay uh it's
particularly of the of the
of the facility that's very important
the overall benefit in this grant is
extremely important
uh and probably one of the ones that are
the most difficult to write
you want to succinctly convey the broad
benefit of the instrument to the greater
research community
you want to place it in the context of
the core facility and communicate its
broad benefit to
the facility and to the research
infrastructure of the university
and then they want you to answer how
will this instrument
benefit your major and minor users and
move the field
forward that is what is the impact
overall
okay and that's really important that
you
consider that they want to look at a
very broad
uh and important impact in science
because
obviously the nih has spent a lot of
money on your grants
they're going to spend a lot of money on
this instrument and they want to know
that it's going to provide a major
impact
in in um to the greater research
community and it's going to be broad and
it's going to be
it's going to be significant so that has
to be worded in a way
that i think uh really i think captures
that
and uh that'll probably be one of the
harder ones to write
the biosketches which go on the grant uh
i only
want to say that they must be unique for
this grant they want to show your
technical expertise
on the instrument okay so you're not
just going to be cutting and pasting
from other biosketches
for this one and there are six areas
that are used in scoring the grant
overall impact and benefit justification
of its need
technical expertise the research
projects that show it need
administration and institutional
commitment those are the six areas that
they
use to score it and the important
sections are
the justifications of use by the major
users the use
tie it to the nih grants is the
equipment essential
for the for the research that's been
funded by the nih
um justification the instrument there is
no other instrument like it
and there's no regular access to an
instrument you're requesting so you have
to show that this is really it
you have to have this instrument to go
forward there's no other access there's
no other instrument like it
expertise of shared facility staff to
maintain it
and commitment of your institution to
maintain the instrument the grant won't
pay again for upkeep
okay so things that you should
care about when you're writing this
grant is the nih really cares about
leveraging
previous projects and that's so they
want you want to demonstrate the
longevity of the instrument and growth
recruitment of users so you want to show
not only
you know how they're going to
immediately benefit but in the long
range
how is this instrument that's going to
sit in our core facility really going to
move the field forward and obviously
you're looking out maybe
four eight ten years um
how is it going to benefit um the user
and you know that you are going to
maintain this thing
and upgrade it as necessary and
and it's important to to show that
scientific applications that are
transformative give high priority and of
course anything that you buy
through the hei application should be
transformative these are
transformative get high priority it's
going to transform science
so the hei grant is more competitive so
when possible
you might want to submit the sig grant
instead of an hei
if over the 600 000 limit the
institutional
support for the remaining difference
might make a strong proposal because it
will show that your institute is
obviously
committed uh to getting one of these
instruments so that might be
uh one one strategy if you um
uh think well gee let's go for the sag
instead of the agi
we'll kick in 400 000 to get the sense
to it
whatever uh is needed um
if you but if you don't emphasize the
need for the equipment
clearly the rest of the grant won't even
matter uh
and will score low or even not get
scored if you're
just replacing an older instrument
that's fine but you're competing with a
lot of applications so it's better if
you can demonstrate the need
show an increased number of users you
need a higher resolution or whatever the
need is
it's got to be clearly shown and
even if it's obvious include a
comparison of other instruments
to show that this is the only instrument
that's really going to be
to give you what you want um
so you want to get preliminary data um
rather than just saying well this
instrument will do it better seek out
centers core facilities loader
instruments
major users will drive the need for this
grant if you
include about five to eight major users
uh that would be good but don't go
overboard if you had 10 then each will
only have about a 10
accessible time and therefore won't be
any longer a major user so
so you don't want too many that that
will uh that will be a problem
so to give you an idea if you will go to
the uh
the url at the bottom of the web page at
the bottom it's an orip
webpage and it shows you the instruments
that are funded
through the s10 program and uh this is
for 2019
it shows at the bottom here a s-10 grant
that was
submitted in 2019 and awarded with
pennsylvania state for
a talos uh arctica g2 instrument two
million dollar instrument
and this is uh by the way i looked up
if you want to do this you can go on nih
reporter
which is nih's website that allows you
to look up any federally funded grant
and this is what you get it only shows
you the abstract and
actually the abstract is includes the
narrative
below but i just wanted to point out
this is their abstract and one of the
things that they said about it
that certainly this was not alone uh
you know responsible for getting the
funds but it gives you the flavor for
the kinds of things so
it tells you what the instrument is it's
to be required to fei
um talus arctica that is a 200 kilovolt
transmission electron microscope
and then it has a fallon uh
3ec direct electron detector and a 12
position
autoloader so those are uh you know
pieces that
are added on to it they're seeking to
acquire the article for vitrification
screening of samples to queue for data
collection on the one-year-old
titan creos which is fully operational
although
overwhelming samples of them most of
them are not ready for data collection
so
it justifies the need for the instrument
an additional
need and to obtain 3d structures from
the cryo
em data single particle reconstructions
rely on collecting
different two-dimensional views of the
same object that are
then reconstructed into 3d maps so it
gives you
you know a flavor for what the
justification what they're going to do
and it says
at the end we identify six major users
three minor users and three other users
using a total of twelve labs
the projects are ready for cryo-em
absolutely depend upon the verification
screening
to succeed and proceed to data
collection and data processing
using single particle reconstruction
approaches and then the narrative which
is written in more of the lay language
says uh this will enable ongoing
research of our established major and
minor users
and that this cryo electron microscope
will be used to investigate
important aspects of viruses proteins
protein complexes polymerase
modulation rna metabolism dna
replication
complex cell wall synthesis
transcription activation and structure
function studies
a photosystem one which is a little
technical
but all of which will significantly
enhance ongoing research projects so it
gives you the broad
uh the broad view of what this
instrument is going to be used for and
that's important to
convey uh in in in your abstract
okay so planning for success on this
thing you want to go six to 12 months in
advance that means starting in november
or december uh for submission in june
2022.
the submission of 2021 is probably
up way too soon at this point being
mid-march
uh because unless you have already
identified all your users and
your administrative panel and all the
other things that
you know with the the facility where
it's going to go
pretty unlikely you've done that already
but if you have you can try for it
um you want to recruit at least three
solid nih-funded investigators with
demonstrated need
and you want to find a wide range of
support again that's important
demo the request and instrument to show
allow your user group to obtain
preliminary data
excuse me that requires advanced
planning obviously
and if you go on the uh par
um announcement um
each of them are a little different but
at the very end the agency context it
shows you people that you can contact
and a lot of people don't pay attention
to this but it's extremely important um
uh jeff wang and uh christina liu
is uh are people that you can call they
give phone numbers and they give emails
and you can call or email them and they
will get back to you
i've done that a number of times it's
very helpful if you want to know
specifics like hey i want to do this is
it the instrument we want
what do you think or hey we have three
three investigators three of them are at
different institutions what would you
advise
you know things that you you can ask
them uh do we have to do this do we have
to do that they're very very helpful
so i would uh recommend calling one of
those people
so one last thing to mention uh before
we finish
is the organization aesthetics of your
brand um
you know no matter how good your
justification is and how well you've
shown the need for this instrument
if it's put together poorly you're going
to fail
and so i would recommend
outlining it to start with
at least the larger sections number your
headings to help reviewers navigate
reviewers and having been one i can
attest to this
they hate when they start seeing a
number of systems that are so long and
you don't know where you are
in the grant if you have a number of sub
headings
so you've got to make sure that the
numbers are clear in only maybe 3.1.1 or
something like that but not
you know a string of four or five
numbers and make
sure all the headings are consistent uh
they're all
the same second headings are bold and
metallic or bold and underlined don't
underline don't bold or italic text
please it drives reviewers nuts just
underline the sections that you feel are
important
and please don't underline an entire
paragraph that is just
ludicrous i mean it's uh you know the
whole brand is important
uh if you find there's a sentence in
there you really want to emphasize
underline it
summary at the end of each section to
help the reviewers
in timelines uh tables uh of timelines
figures of approach
those things help and uh you want your
grant to look like this this is not an
instrument grant but it shows neat
organization with all the figures that
are boxed with a
with the with the captions inside and
um very cl and there's a white space in
there you know a ton
but there's white space and uh
unfortunately
a lot of investigators particularly
those who are new
they just jam everything they can on you
know in the in the allotted number of
pages
uh because they just feel that they get
not going to fit it otherwise and
nothing will anger a reviewer more than
having them look at a a page that is
nothing but one solid block of text
so resist the temptation to do that
even though you have five inch 0.5 inch
margins
and 11 point type don't don't jam it
full of
uh put put a fair amount of white space
in there
one last thing if your grant shows a
critical need for recent adjustment that
the nih wants to fund great
it has high impact and significant a
broad range of research
it's really wonderful but it'll fail
because you have unclear english
you have a lot of errors in punctuation
and spelling and the writing is sloppy
it's not clear it's not concise it's not
logical
and these are the things that are really
really
deal killers i can't tell you how many
times i've read a paper as a
as a as a a journal editor
or a uh or or a grant
i've reviewed hundreds and hundreds of
grants that are full
of errors it just reflects badly on you
on your institution and it also
uh basically says to me well they're not
very
careful about how they put this together
so i don't think they're going to carry
out this research very carefully or very
precisely so you've got to make sure
that your grant is letter perfect
and have other people read it have other
people review it
even if it's just for hey this sentence
doesn't make sense or gee
there's no period here uh there's a
bunch of misspelling errors that's just
deal killers
and that is what i do for a living
generally
i my company medcom consulting with that
email
we review grants from investigators and
um
and also manuscripts so um with that i
leave you and we'll open it up for any
questions you might have
thank you dr dan for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
does each nih-funded major user need
preliminary data
that's a good question i would say yes
um that you want to have
want to show the needs of the instrument
and therefore you need preliminary data
now that that means that you've gathered
you've gathered data on the instrument
some way uh either through a loner
or another instrument at another
institution
uh but you really should have
preliminary data
yes
thank you dr vance and our next question
is a secondary instrument that is that
is used to prepare samples for the
primary instrument requested
permitted to be included in the proposal
okay so as i mentioned
any you know i don't know what a
secondary instrument means
um if it's an adjunct to the main
instrument
such as a super computer uh or
a you know anything that would be
used to gather data to crunch the data
for the main instrument yes it can be
included
uh as long as the as long as the
instrument or as long as the accessory
is used solely for that instrument
by the major users in other words uh
you can't use it uh for other purposes
uh to generate data from you know from
some other instrument or some other
method it has to be dedicated to the
major instrument you're requesting
thank you dr dant our next question here
is
does an r21 qualify an investigator as
major user no it doesn't as i mentioned
only the r21 is not a major user
um a grant you can use no
has to be an r01 a uo one or the other
ones that i mentioned in the
presentation but not an r21 no
or an r03
great thank you so much and we have one
more question here from the audience
you said it is better for the pi to be
nih funded
do you think a facility director would
be a poor choice to be
a pi no they wouldn't be a poor choice
um it you know i got that information
actually from the nih
it helps if they're nih funded but they
do not need to be
uh i think it's fine for them to be a
facility director
the main thing there is that they really
understand the instrument
and can help if there's any problems
with it they can help
say hey you can't run these samples uh
you know they know
the instrument cold they have the
expertise on it so that's really the
major
the pi the pd of the uh of the of the
grant should be
if they have nih funding great but they
don't have to be
that's true thank you dr dan do you have
any final comments for our audience
today
oh um okay well i would just say that
um these these grants are very different
than the r01s or the one
other our grants that you're used to so
it's very important that you go to the
uh the um go to the uh par
the the i'm sorry the rfa that i
mentioned in each of these
um uh grants and take a look at it and
read
particularly section four which tells
you how to apply
it's very important that you get a real
strong flavor for this before you start
writing anything and putting putting in
a grant but
again they're very winnable uh 18 to 20
percent acceptance rate
and uh i would say that um you know
they're really a great source
of funding for investigators thanks
thank you again dr dan for your time
today and for your
important presentation we would also
like to thank labruz and our sponsor
thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye